Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In an earlier work, we were able to change
a photo of an already existing design according
to our taste.
That was absolutely amazing.
But now, hold onto your papers and have a
look at this!
Because here, we can create something out
of thin air!
The input in this problem formulation is an
image, and the output is an image of a different
kind.
Let's call this process image translation.
It is translation in a sense, that for instance,
we can add an aerial view of a city as an
input, and get the map of this city as an
output.
Or, we can draw the silhouette of a handbag,
and have it translated to an actual, real-looking
object.
And we can go even crazier, for instance,
day to night conversion of a photograph is
also possible.
What an incredible idea, and look at the quality
of the execution.
Ice cream for my eyes.
And, as always, please don't think of this
algorithm as the end of the road - like all
papers, this is a stepping stone, and a few
more works down the line, the kinks will be
fixed, and the output quality is going to
be vastly improved.
The technique uses a conditional adversarial
network to accomplish this.
This works the following way: there is a generative
neural network that creates new images all
day, and a discriminator network is also available
all day to judge whether these images look
natural or not.
During this process, the generator network
learns to draw more realistic images, and
the discriminator network learns to tell fake
images from real ones.
If they train together for long enough, they
will be able to reliably create these image
translations for a large set of different
scenarios.
There are two key differences that make this
piece of work stand out from the classical
generative adversarial networks:
One - both neural networks have the opportunity
to look at the before and after images.
Normally we restrict the problem to only looking
at the after images, the final results.
And two - instead of only positive, both positive
and negative examples are generated.
This means that the generator network is also
asked to create really bad images on purpose
so that the discriminator network can more
reliably learn the distinction between flippant
attempts and quality craftsmanship.
Another great selling point here is that we
don't need several different algorithms for
each of the cases, the same generic approach
is used for all the maps and photographs,
the only thing that is different is the training
data.
Twitter has blown up with fun experiments,
most of them include cute drawings ending
up as horrifying looking cats.
As the title of the video says, the results
are always going to be stunning, but sometimes,
a different kind of stunning than we'd expect.
It's so delightful to see that people are
having a great time with this technique and
it is always a great choice to put out such
a work for a wide audience to play with.
And if you got excited for this project, there
are tons, and I mean tons of links in the
video description, including one to the source
code of the project, so make sure to have
a look and read up some more on the topic,
there's going to be lots of fun to be had!
You can also try it for yourself, there is
a link to an online demo in the description
and if you post your results in the comments
section, I guarantee there will be some amusing
discussions.
I feel that soon, a new era of video games
and movies will dawn where most of the digital
models are drawn by computers.
As automation and mass-producing is a standard
in many industries nowadays, we'll surely
be hearing people going: "Do you remember
the good old times when video games were handcrafted?
Man, those were the days!".
If you enjoyed this episode, make sure to
subscribe to the series, we try our best to
put out two of these videos per week.
We would be happy to have have join our growing
club of Fellow Scholars and be a part of our
journey to the world of incredible research
works such as this one.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!